good evening welcome it's good to have
you I'm Matthew Spalding I'm the
associate vice president Dean for
Hillsdale College here in Washington DC
welcome to the Allen P Kirby Center for
consular staff in citizenship which is
our forward deployment of Hillsdale
College in the nation's capital hills of
college as most of you know as an old
institution based in Michigan found in
1844 that from the beginning was
anti-slavery and opened its doors to all
regardless of race religion or sex and
today it remains vigorously independent
among other things not accepting any
government money and the reason we do
that is to maintain our independence so
that we can remain a trustee of the
Western philosophical and Theological
inheritance tracing to Athens to
Jerusalem which we believe find its
clearest expression in the American idea
in the American experiment our mission
is to teach those ideas and it follows
that we have always been less interested
in labels and isms like conservatism and
more interested in thoughts and actions
of politics we'd rather focus on
conserving the liberating principles of
the American Revolution for instance and
so we teach about politics
constitutional and the prudence of
statecraft which is what we will be
teaching in a graduate school we will
soon be opening here in Washington DC to
teach those things our speaker today is
Michael Anton who was a lecturer and
research fellow here at the Kirby Center
he received his BA from the University
of California Davis a master's of
liberal arts degree from st. John's
College in Annapolis and a master's
degree in government from the Claremont
Graduate University prior to joining
Hillsdale College he served in the Trump
administration as deputy administered to
the president's for strategic
communications he's written for numerous
publications many of which you've seen
some famous some infamous I suppose
including the Washington Post the
journal Wall Street Journal Weekly
Standard and I know he's also a senior
fellow at the Claremont Institute his
topic this evening the topic this
evening the end of conservatism and the
rebirth of politics why can't I
[Applause]
this is kind of scary rides me Peggy
Noonan's little book on to be tried
again she said that people's number one
fear typically is public speaking I've
actually had to do it a lot over the
last year and a half or so and I thought
they've gotten kind of easy you know
nothing to worry about and so I asked
Matt well well you know like script
something out or just get up there and
wing it that's what I've been doing
lately
you don't have to script it out but you
don't really want to wing it either so I
wrote an outline and that actually came
up with the title I had come up I came
up with something incredibly witty like
the proper relationship between the
general and the particular and I sent
that to him and he wrote back in email I
can't remember he spelled out the word I
can't remember it was grown or yawn but
it was one or the other and so I said
alright I gotta do something to
something else then he said what about
this that's good that's good that works
I can I can talk about that open was a
little warning one of my favorite
teachers not a teacher cuz I never knew
him but I read all his books and it's
you know studied his arguments with care
Leo Strauss said I think isn't a letter
somewhere he said the title of a book or
a piece or an article should never
reflect what's actually in the contents
you need to let the reader figure that
out for himself so I'll leave it to you
to figure out whether I actually do talk
about the end of conservatism and the
return of politics one of these you
learn from Strauss is you read all the
Platonic dialogues and they're all
centered around what is question right
so of course that's where we have to
start what is conservatism I use
Lincoln's definition from the well I'll
tell you where it's from back so I'm
getting ahead of my own outline what is
conservatism said Lincoln is it not the
adherents to the old and tried against
the new and untried it's a decent
definition I would say but notice what
Lincoln does not say there he doesn't
say conservatism is true he doesn't say
it's good he doesn't say it's right he
doesn't say it's just he doesn't say it
isn't any of these things either but he
doesn't evaluate conservatism at all he
just sort of tells you what what it's
trying to do in terms of newness and
boldness right so I would say we have to
step back conservatism can't really be
in itself a governing or guiding Prince
for what we're trying to do you know for
instance old nough sits at the old and
tried right well as a graduate student
friend of mine once said in a seminar
that got incredibly heated but in a good
way
he said you know what second only to the
family slavery is the oldest human
institution in the world we wouldn't say
it's good right as for its being tried
in Linkous terms we know it works I put
that in quotes for the this is for the
c-span audience it's good it works for
the slaveholder right old and tried
therefore there cannot be a standard for
the good what's Lincoln doing here is
using rhetoric he's appealing to a
popular prejudice the quote comes from
the Cooper Union speech which if you've
not read it I urge everyone to read it
it's very long complicated it's not as
great as speech it's not as most
stirring but it's his most
intellectually impressive his law
partner said in both aw and lament
because I think he thought like to cost
them a lot of money because Lincoln
wasn't really working that he spent the
better part of a year working on it so
at the time speech was given in February
of 1864 Lincoln's election to president
but it's essentially made him the
Republican nominee his Republican Party
was being accused of radicalism and
seeking to keep slavery out of the
territories so they were being called
the anti conservatives they're the
rabble rousers the agitators right his
great opponent Lincoln's that is in 1858
and 60 Stephen Douglas appealed to the
founders in support of his position that
slavery should be subject to a majority
vote Douglass said something like that
we should govern ourselves in this
matter as in all matters as did our
forefathers before us like it said okay
I'm gonna put that to the test
I'm gonna go research what they actually
thought on this question he delved
through tons of archives in every single
place where a vote was taken on the
question of federal authority to exclude
slavery from the territories he found
that a majority in most cases a
supermajority of those founders who
place to vote said we have the power to
keep it out right so Lincoln turns
Douglass's argument back against itself
he destroys Douglas his appeal to the
founders they're both making the same
appeal we're going back where the
Conservatives I'm the conservative you
know we could say I'm the conservative
you're saying you're the conservative
all who's really right on this question
turns the argument is rhetorically
brilliant I would argue but
intellectually limited right what is the
American Founding
is that not the new and the untried in a
certain respect you know they the
founders so they called it an experiment
they used two Latin phrase Novus Ordo
seclorum a new order for the ages
is there a conservatism that must be
open to risk and to the new I would
argue that of course there should be and
I don't think Lincoln disagreed with me
what he's doing in that speech is
rhetoric that's not an adequate that may
be an adequate definition of
conservatism but it shows the limits of
what conservatism is or what it can do
so I'm gonna mention Strauss again I
think I'm gonna mention at least one
more time just letting you know after
this
he taught that philosophies the
awareness of permanent problems and one
such is the inherent tension between the
right and the just on the one hand and
an adventure is a more newness on the
other the Declaration of Independence
and they give you a fairly long quote
but I think it's very important it says
prudence indeed will dictate that
governments long established should not
be changed for light and transient
causes and accordingly all experience
hath shown that mankind are more
disposed to suffer evils while evils are
sufferable than to right themselves by
abolishing the forms to which they are
accustomed so the point here is if you
go too far in one direction you get
stasis and injustice forever do you just
accept injustice and wrong because
conservatism is old and tried and
anything new is radical you go too far
in the other direction you get
utopianism every evil must be righted
every problem is urgent we got to do it
right now and whatever China and egg is
we have to break it it's it's not only
is the cost worth it but there's almost
a moral necessity to doing it right the
only solution here is prudence going to
know what to do in a given circumstance
the American founders you know you could
make a case either way once it was it
was the did they need to do what they
did when they did it they had to argue
about that there were people who didn't
want to do it people didn't want the
revolution and they made good arguments
I'm not saying they were right they made
good arguments it's not obvious requires
prudence prudence requires knowing the
good which requires philosophy in other
words conservatism has to look up to
something above itself the question of
what it conserves absolutely matters
conservatism today when I now from from
this point on when I say conservatism
you know
I mean kind of a an an ideology mindset
in some respects in industry
conservatism likes to say that it has a
philosophy I also have that in quotes
but once you put an article in front of
the world and watch in other words once
you say a philosophy or the philosophy
you know the philosophy of so-and-so
you've changed the meaning of the word
philosophy literally means love of
wisdom it's a process of recent
investigation that never ends when you
say I have a philosophy you're implying
that the investigation is over that
you've figured everything out but have
you really just want to describe a scene
from a book that I love that I urge you
all to read it's called the education of
Sirus by Xena Fong and it's the story of
the founder of the Persian Empire Cyrus
the Great although all the biographical
details are made up because Xena phones
really not trying to tell you the
biography of the founder of the Persian
Empire he's trying to teach political
lessons so young Cyrus has a political
project he wants to take Persia and make
it into something else make it bigger
grander better richer more powerful and
he runs into the conservatism of the
Persian peers including his own family
who are the constitutional monarchs they
don't have a lot of power they're sort
of like a constitutional monarch today
symbols of the principles of the regime
so as he's going out on his project he
has a conversation with his father and
in this convert stage by the way book
one chapter six if you want to read the
conversation which I recommend he
essentially says I know what I'm doing
dad I know what the good is I know what
this project entails don't worry about
it everything's gonna be fine and his
father's kind of a stand-in for Socrates
in this conversation he pokes holes in
all Cyrus's arguments it kind of shows
it he doesn't really know he's not sure
Cyrus is wrong but Cyrus doesn't really
know and he has not examined his own
case for what the good is okay but this
points to another one of those insoluble
problems or tensions how do you act when
you don't know what to do when you don't
know what is the good right so famously
Socrates always claimed he only had
knowledge of ignorance fundamentally the
only not true knowledge he had was
knowledge of ignorance he spent a whole
lifetime investigating the noble and the
good and the just and he claimed it as
he died he still didn't know what it was
seventy years old then again if you
never act until you know you'll never
act her alysus
you know an analogy that I've used which
is glib but they're from not therefore
inaccurate is you can't have a dialectic
about the noble of a good when the tank
is coming at you you got to do something
you either got to get out of the way or
try to stop the tank alright so the
important thing though for I just I
wrote here study the good I'm trying to
that's a little bit glib what I meant
what I mean to say at this point is you
have to study the good even with full
knowledge and awareness that you may
never get to it completely adequate
understanding if Socrates didn't then we
probably won't either but the fact that
you never get to a full and adequate
analysis a proof of what the good is
doesn't mean you no longer have an
obligation to study it nor doesn't mean
you can't ever figure out anything about
what it is the blessing from Socrates
and from other philosophers is to be
humble about what you think you know be
open to change there's a famous quote
often attributed to Lincoln and I looked
it up thinking it was like and I was
going to put it as Lincoln but
apparently nobody can prove where it
came from it might have been John
Maynard Keynes we don't even know that
either but it's good it's good quote it
fits the purpose right when the facts
change I changed my mind what do you do
right so when conservatives say they
have a philosophy what they really mean
is that they have an ideology some even
use the phrase ideology in a none ironic
and positive way maybe it's one of those
words that's more morphed over time but
initially it kind of it meant something
something lower something kind of
degraded in philosophy what an ideology
is is a kind of popular philosophy which
presents conclusions that philosophy
leaves open so the true philosopher of
course disdains ideology but ideology is
fine as long as we recognize it for what
it is for its limitations I would say
it's even necessary as a practical way
to solve the what now problem in any
political situation in any situation you
got to deliberate about what to do we're
not allowed to just step back and say
well you know since I can't make up my
mind let's just not do anything life
doesn't work that way so we need an
ideology but it always has to be open to
revision and that's where I think
conservatism lost its way now I just say
this following I'm not on Twitter I
intend never to be on Twitter if you
ever find me on Twitter come to my house
and shoot me
quill pens ink wells in parchment or my
speed when it comes to information
technology but I do know what a hashtag
is and if there were one hashtag to
define conservatism over the last decade
at least maybe longer it would be
hashtag capital a always 1980 I have
nothing against 1980 it was a good year
for me personally I was 10 so I couldn't
vote but and I knew nothing about
politics but I later learned and came to
appreciate Reagan and looked back with
fondness that he won the 1980 election
that he rebuilt the military that he cut
taxes that he jump-started the Americana
all that stuff I think is good but
Reagan's policy solutions were carefully
designed and calibrated for his time by
Reagan himself there's I just I don't
have this here but this is a little
aside you noted one of the the most
famous quote from Reagan's first
inaugural is government is not the
solution to our problems government is
the problem
everybody cuts out there's a parent
there's a phrase before a comma right in
front of that in this present crisis in
this present crisis right in other words
that's not a mantra for all time
not a mantra' for every crisis in it
maybe it's not a mantra for non crises
when conservatism came to believe that
Reagan's policies would work for all
time or timeless some probably are but
not all and then there's the matter of
priorities when a top marginal tax rate
is 70 percent as it was in 1918 tax cuts
are a very high priority when they're in
the 30s not so much or if you want
instead of 1980 you can pick 1955 why do
I choose that because it's the year of
the foundation of National Review what
is National Review do fundamentally know
you laugh I'm not here to bury or
criticize National Review it's certainly
not in its 1955 dispensation
what did National Review I mean
Buckley's big achievement there aside
from giving a voice in a venue to
writers who didn't have really an outlet
was to see these disparate threads that
had maybe that weren't talking to each
other but maybe had something in common
and put them together this came to be
called fusion ISM right and the three
threads were the traditional religious /
conservatives who were very concerned
with morality the economic conservatives
and libertarians and the foreign policy
Hawks again necessary to do for its time
and a spectacular achievement in fact so
I'm not here to criticize them I'm here
to criticize us and yes that includes me
I was once a movement conservative just
like a lot of people in this room maybe
most of people in this room so this is
very much a self-criticism my point is
that the Ragan Buckley is people who net
and Lincoln the people who met the
crises of their time did what the
conservative movement as I've seen it
hasn't been able to do in the last 10 or
20 years that is they went to a
reservoir of deeper ideas and they used
them to examine their own time what did
Lincoln do he went back to the founding
the founding were asking fund the
foundation fundamentals what is the
purpose of politics what is the good
Society what does justice require what
is justice itself I want to tell very
short anecdote there so you know I said
every platonic dialogue is of what is
question that's of course the question
the Republic what is justice so when
Harvey Mansfield was teaching in
Berkeley in the early 60s Leo Strauss
Benison semester at Stanford people who
knew both of them Harry Jaffa in
particular said you gotta you gotta go
see this guy every as much as you can
and some still would drive across the
bay and see Strauss every weekend they
read the Republican with some other
students like one of the first things
Strauss apparently asked him was what is
the question that the center of this
dialogue and the room is silent and
they're all like he's too poor like what
if I get the wrong answer in front of
this brilliant man nobody talks like
clock ticked by finally Mansfield said
what is justice yes this light answer
and he felt so relieved I got the right
answer this genius it recognizes that I
got the right answer it was an easy
question he thought maybe there's a
trick in there somewhere
okay we we go back to the founding we
get fundamental questions we go back to
1980 what do we get we get tax cuts
Enterprise Zones small government be
tough on the Russians now that these are
bad things but they don't address the
fundamental issues of 2016 or 2018 so
I'm gonna give you another quote this is
the chapter title of book 3 chapter 1 of
the discourses of Machiavelli it is
entitled if one wishes a sect or a
republic to live long it is necessary to
draw it back often toward its beginnings
I'm not gonna tell you what he really
means by that but it's a lot because
it's a lot meaner than it sounds but you
know for the four conservatives the
beginning is 1980 or maybe 1980 55 for
some I think it even moved further
forward in time and there's a there's a
pretty big wing of the conservative
movement which now would say the whole
1980 platform is much too mean and harsh
you know they maybe point to compassion
a conservative of 2000 one of the things
conservatism is done lately is its
jettisoned a lot of what is best in its
useful past okay so I would say the real
beginning for us is the founders of
founding the American founding and the
principles which underlay it which some
of which are contemporary to its time
some of which belonged to the early
modern period some of which go all the
way back to the classical area now
conservatives all agree they say they
all agree the one thing they will say
they all agree on is they love the
founding I love the founding but like
Cyrus and the good in the conversation
with his father they think they
understand it but I question whether
they really do now this is another
Strauss quote I think is the last one he
wrote a book in 1949 called on tyranny
1949 s four years after the end of World
War two Stalin's conquered half of
Europe he's a very bad man and Russian
the Soviet empires going strong Strauss
writes an analysis of tyranny and he
makes an indictment against his fellow
political scientists he says when we
were brought face to face with tyranny
with a kind of tyranny that surpassed
the boldest imagination of the most
powerful thinkers of the past our
political science failed to recognize it
he's essentially saying if you're a
doctor and I bring into you a terminal
cancer patient you
tell me that he has cancer then you
don't know what you're doing well I
would flip that on to the Conservatives
the American people were presented with
the most conservative founder like
presidential candidate a generation our
Conservatives failed to recognize it
now that's people that's gonna sound
crazy Trump the least conservative
Republican ever is deviates from any
principles all across the board how can
you say that well what do you think the
Founding is about I think I know what
I'm gonna guess at what's in the heads
of a lot of people in this room liberty
freedom rights equality Constitution all
those are essential no doubt about it
but the real the core of the founding
what the founders are trying to do is
protection the protection of rights the
protections person the protection of
property protection of the country
itself of the physical country itself of
its communities of its industries and so
on if we go back to the founding the pre
founding beginning the true beginning we
find a fundamental another fundamental
philosophic to sting shion's that
between mere life and the good life you
can't have the ladder without the former
and the founders understood this I'll
just make a small aside which I left out
because it goes down kind of a rabbit
hole but you know this is one of those
ancients and modern distinctions is the
MA ancients and the moderns would say of
course have to have mere life the basis
of protection is fundamental
no no disagreement there how much is the
state or the polis or whatever get
involved in a good life
the ancients would say a lot right maybe
almost overwhelmingly so there's a line
floating around out there that came up
on an email list I'm on it goes
something like the ancient formula is
anything the law does not command it
forbids whereas the modern formula is
anything the law does not forbid it
permits okay founders would say the
station have a lot less it should leave
you free to pursue the good life have a
lot less involvement but not zero
involvement they were not libertarians
they you know they were strongly for
laws inculcating virtue promoting
religion and so on and so forth okay now
I'm not saying that our conservatives
would deny any of this
they wouldn't they said of course yeah
and I'm gonna give give him credit
they've done some great work on this
theme in particular I mean what movement
has done more to protect lives property
in society then the great crime-fighting
movement that
essentially launched by conservative
intellectuals in Manhattan Institute and
put in place by conservative mayors and
governors since the late 80s and early
90s it's one of the great conservative
policy success stories of my lifetime
maybe the single greatest but
conservatism failed to protect us in
three fundamental ways on immigration
trade and foreign policy now this is not
a policy speech I'm not gonna go into
this in great detail although I'm sure
you'll have questions and I'll happy to
answer and I do have strong thoughts on
all three but I mostly want to answer
why why didn't they recognize it so yet
another philosophic distinction that
between the form and the matter right in
political terms the form is the regime
or the principle the matter is the
people the land stop the buildings the
industries the resources there's a
there's a line in Francis Bacon when he
quotes the dangers of a little
philosophy a little philosophy dolphin
Kleinman's Minds to atheism but depth in
the subject bringeth them back around to
God I think that's exactly what sure I
didn't write it down
so conservatives they got a little
philosophy about first principle and
they fell in love with it and
essentially what I think happened is
they slogan eyes the founding principles
you'll love to quote the declaration we
all quote the declaration but we only
quote the second paragraph everybody we
all these truths of yourself haven't
really know secretary how do you know
the first paragraph
I'll read it wouldn't know and when you
hear me like emphasize my voice and sort
of yell a little that means it's bolded
and that's on the page right when in the
course of human events it becomes
necessary for one people to dissolve the
political bands which have connected
them with another and to assume among
the powers of the earth the separate and
equal station to which the laws of
nature and nature's God entitle them a
decent respect to the opinions of
mankind requires that they should
declare the causes which impel them to
that separation what is the founding
fundamentally or at least at the basic
level it's when we declared ourselves to
people the principles of paragraph two
are declared to be true for all mankind
what the founders would not pretend that
they had the power to apply them to all
mankind nor would they say even if they
had that power that they had any right
to do so remember the separate and equal
station it's right there in paragraph
one nations are entitled to a separate
and equal station entitled by nature and
nations nature and nature's God Lincoln
called the second paragraph
famously referred to the declaration
itself is a merely revolutionary
document it's just stating in fact we
could and he says absolutely could have
written that document without the second
paragraph at all didn't have to put any
political theory in it but it's there to
state for all time the basis of
political legitimacy this is how we how
we define justice now we based
legitimacy and our regime going forward
will no longer be on the Divine Right of
Kings or aristocratic principles or any
of the things that prevailed in the
Europe at the time and Lincoln also said
that statement was in there in order to
be forever a stumbling block to future
tyrants and future oppression that it
would that it would galvanize the minds
of the people and make them aware or
more aware and more apt to fight back
should such oppressors arise so I would
say the reason the Conservatives missed
the Trump phenomenon is because they
don't really understand trade and
immigration which is because they don't
understand first principle or maybe they
forgot I don't know I'm trying I'm being
a little more generous they recoil at
any talk as Americans as a separate
people because they think has violate
some first principle now that's maybe a
little bit of an overstatement but it's
getting more radical out there I think
with the immigration debate they forgot
the proper relationship of the general
forum to the particular matter so there
I got my title in my lecture in anyway
so on this question the ancients
understand chance understand Plato and
Aristotle and the founders they agree
there's only one best regime it's true
for all times in places it's not always
practicable meaning possible to set up
or even if you could set it up to make
it last and in fact it very rarely will
be practicable
it's practablity practicability depends
on the matter whether the given matter
is capable of sustaining and you all
know the very famous Ben Franklin quote
walks out of the Constitutional
Convention what did you give us mr.
Franklin a monarchy a republic is a
republic if you can keep it that's an
awareness of the importance of matter to
the regime that the form the matter has
to fit the form and vice versa the fact
that there are universal truths does not
obviate another fact namely that all
politics is inherently particular there
will always be separate cities nations
and countries entitled to separate and
stations one of the points of the SCI
rope idea is to you know point out the
limits of that understanding essentially
Zeena Phan just like Plato in their
public is making this sort of the same
point ultimately the distinction between
citizen and non citizen may be arbitrary
in the sense that where the line is
drawn there's not always a clear line
but that there will always be a line is
a fundamental fact of human nature which
is why one world government is both
impossible and undesirable now this may
be this is definitely glib and it may be
slightly unfair but not therefore wholly
inaccurate
I think the conserve the Conservatives
allowed their misunderstanding a form to
convince them that principle requires
globalization we are all to UM Friedman
now in the conservative movement
certainly they think it requires free
trade I think there's some economic
principle that absolutely requires free
trade and protection is the worst thing
you could possibly do and it's almost an
affront to the national dignity of every
American this is kind of hilarious the
very first law of the United States
Congress passed after it became
operational was the Tariff Act of 1789
now it wasn't exactly the first law they
passed a couple of sort of housekeeping
managerial law but the first substantive
law they passed was the Tariff Act of
1789 you can't appeal to Lincoln either
was a thoroughgoing protectionist and
the entire Lincoln inspired Republican
Party that dominated American politics
from 1865 until the Progressive Era was
also protectionist
so I'm not denouncing free trade I'm
saying it's a policy it depends on the
context there are times in which it's
good for us and there are times in which
maybe it doesn't work it out it
certainly worked out extremely well for
the United States from 1945 to 1965
maybe you could stretch that 75 actually
Reagan understood the dangers have free
trade better than the Conservatives
today who appealed to him and introduced
a number of protections measures and and
arguably saved the US auto industry by
doing things to the Japanese auto
industry that conservatives today would
find completely in Africa the founders
on immigration similar they knew it
depended on the context and the founding
area you see a lot of argument from
leading founders saying we've this giant
continent that's that we didn't have the
whole continent yet but if you think
about it and I think on the eve of the
revolution and 13 colonies are about
three million people and they said
that's a lot of people we can't even
hold it we can't hold this land with
that people we need more people for our
own safety and security they made this
argument immigration is good for the
existing citizenry
let's welcome in some people but they're
asking the right question do we the
people need more people sometimes we do
right the failure to understand
principle I would argue also has real
rhetorical implications I'm hearing this
more and more from conservatives anytime
you bring up the particular they
immediate their amigo - it's like a just
a gut reaction or a rash or something is
identity politics and that's bad that's
what the left is it's bad only talk
about universals anytime you talk about
anything particular not universal you're
engaging in identity politics this
misunderstanding of principle I think is
weaponized by the left and used against
the Conservatives and they haven't still
haven't really caught on icon I'm trying
to help them they don't want to hear it
you can trust me
your principles mean that the left will
say to them your principles mean that
you must be for open borders and they'll
go they don't want to believe you know
but they they think they tie themselves
in knots trying to think of a principle
dancer or they given and agree the
founders would just simply say what are
you talking about right we the people
get to decide that that's the principle
of republicanism the founders would also
say and this is an argument the
conservatives really get super upset
about is that it depends on the matter
or the suitability for republicanism of
the people you're admitting they make
this argument very openly we're doing an
experiment right remember when the
founders found the United States of
America the last there's really only one
arguably one arguably - I would say
successful Republic's in the world at
that time Switzerland or the Swiss
Confederacy in them and in other words
and the Netherlands is nominally ruled
by a Habsburg monarch out of Madrid
so that and so the last experience that
the the West had with Republic's would
be the Renaissance and they were all
disasters the founders have to make it
this is what Federalist one through six
is made then making a case for why
republicanism is not a complete failure
in human terms but it can be revived and
it ought to be revived but then they say
it's gonna be sustained we have to make
sure that the character of the people
remains Republican which they say has a
lot to do with what we're gonna do on
emigrate I'm sorry on education policy
but on immigration policy
well services cannot bear that thought
they think it's ruled out by their
principles and as a result they concede
a huge amount of vital ground
and they lose arguments which I think
they we've been doing for a while
another way we lose is to accept the
tyranny of expertise
the modern left drawing from Hegel and
others asserts that there are no
fundamentally political questions that
is just question switch there's no
necessary right or wrong answer or the
that is to say correct or incorrect
answer there might be a right or wrong
answer there are only issues or problems
you know they're correct or incorrect
and naturally the left has all the
solutions and they have the research
university which I analogize to the
pre-revolutionary monasteries of France
which Napoleon's spent a serious amount
of time and effort breaking out for a
good reason and and and it's it's the
analogy is more apt than you think I
mean they're the rich I didn't coined
this term but I wish I had decent I mean
I'm all for hills dales endowment may it
may it grow in perpetuity but colleges
that are teaching bad things and doing
bad things to the society I mean you
know we have to recognize their their
hedge funds with these little schools
attached and there and another analogy
to pre-revolutionary France you member
one of the reasons that the French
Revolution happens because the nobility
didn't have to pay taxes so the richest
people in the society and have to pay
taxes the universities don't pay taxes
the guys who manage their hedge funds
pay the the so-called two-and-twenty no
I'm sorry the investor pays that and the
carried interest loophole so they make a
lot of money they don't have to pay
ordinary income tax on it I call that
the tax-exempt nobility it's certainly
the tax privilege nobility it's not good
okay so conservatism too often foolishly
accepts this that okay all these are
questions of expertise so we just have
to come up with a better argument well
as we're gonna do a better policy paper
we're gonna run the numbers we're gonna
win so then our expertise will get to
decide the solution but that's not the
game the left is playing against them I
don't think they realize it
it's the game they tell us they're
playing and then I think we are dumb
enough to believe it
we're losing the rhetorical war because
we don't understand first principle we
don't know how to apply principle to the
challenges of our time and we and
because we came to mistake policies for
principles now
almost done there is a conservative
reaction against this which i think is
healthy and good but it's inchoate and
it's there's a problem in its core which
is that the people who see the problems
with currents are a lot of them who see
the problems with current conservatism
say that the problem is the principal
right
they just equate principles with
universalism and they say so the
solution is just to abandon principle
and we'll just gonna go back to the
particular altogether it always tramples
the particular I first say first of all
that's logically not true it explain it
but it would take there's a little bit
of a proof it takes a bit so I'll skip
that but also this is important the
founders didn't believe that right so to
those in the the traditionalist right or
whatever want to call them who invoke
American history customs traditions etc
I sympathize I want to preserve all of
those things two fundamental question
what is conservatism trying to conserve
those are some of the things
conservatism ought to be trying to
conserve but tradition fundamentally is
about the passion of love of one's own
this is the problem with traditional ISM
is it doesn't it can't give you an
account of why tradition is good some
traditions are good we should defend
them on that basis but if you don't know
what the good is or haven't I have no
idea what the good is or if you deny the
existence of the good you have no basis
on which to say tradition is good that's
not my point here though my point is the
founding is it's love of one's own is
the passion that the traditionals want
to take us back to away from a sort of
radical particularism well the founding
is our own so it's self contradictory to
denounce the founding principles or
principles in general and then say you
want to appeal to American unnecessary
and then say yeah but we want to appeal
to America and what wasn't my America is
what we're trying to say all right so
everybody you're always supposed to
close them what do we do now to which I
would say I don't know but I have some
answers the first task is to understand
principle correctly and that's within
reach we can do it cuz there's books out
there that explain and there's teachers
who know it there's no reason why we
have to get first principle in such a
mess there's no reason for it at least
there's no reason why we can't clean
that up that's achievable and it's
achievable in the near term the second
is to just not be afraid once we learn
the principle stop conceding rhetorical
ground to the left as if they understand
our principles better than we do and
we'll keep losing the third is we need
to have honest debates amongst ourselves
about how to apply principle to policy
and we have to recognize that those
debates or political debates they're not
debates about expertise about corrected
false they are in a philosophic and
perhaps theological sense debates about
right and wrong but we need to
understand that in a sense the political
spheres being either taken away from us
or vastly constricted and we need to get
it back so we can look to the founders
for the first task for sure we can look
to the founders for the second be not
afraid or fight back we can't really
look to them for the third we can't
their ideas will not supply us with
recipes for today's use only we living
today can possibly find a solution to
the problems of today they can give us
the basis on which to find those
solutions and that's where we need to
start looking and I think ultimately
that's why I'm here at Hillsdale working
here now dream job very happy to be here
look forward to doing it for many years
to come I think that's what the college
is trying to do in a broad sense and I
would include in all of that which I
left out of the talk specifically but
not just America but the whole West the
whole West the whole civilizational
project of the West is what we're trying
to conserve fight for correctly
understand it's whether we're gonna win
we could win the argument we're gonna
win the fight I don't know but I'll
quote I didn't write this part down but
I will quote Machiavelli one more time
he lays out the sort of fundamental
alternative between two courses of
action the discourses book one chapter
six and he's like reason can't really
make a case for either one of these you
know you know you could argue this you
could argue that it's got a strong case
for it against for both of them so he
says take the Honorable course and do
this one take the Honorable course and
fight even if you even if you think
you're gonna lose all in there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. Anton thank you so much for coming
and speaking definitely thank you again
or but I want to ask about is you
mentioned mr. Lincoln mr. Lincoln was
someone who said that Henry Clay was his
beau of an ideal statesman and yet Henry
Clay would have been horrified by the
Homestead Act that mr. Lincoln signed
it's contrary to his policy of how to
form land in the West so my question is
in terms of in the administration of
public policy from a perspective of
conservatism but moreover trueness to
first principles when does one in the
sense change one's principles not prints
change principles sorry change how one's
planned to administer and work within
government versus what is the plans of
the times I'm not sure I understood the
question I'll give you a little I'll
give you a little Auto pseudo
autobiographical account I was always a
free trader I thought conservative
principles demanded it it's what I
didn't study much economics or what I
studied seemed like you know it's a
matter of expertise free trade is
superior in as a matter of justice it's
required I took that view into 2015 and
all of a sudden here comes along a
presidential candidate who I'd like to
do saying on immigration for sure
and he made sense to me on foreign
policy but I thought on trade he's
terrible he's nuts he made me go back
and rethink it and look it up just try
to figure something out right revisit
the arguments eternity changed my mind
on trade or he led me to the path have
changed my mind on the trade and I've
come around to this view that trade is
is not a principle it's contextual
what's good for us in this moment what's
good for the United States its citizenry
its communities its industries and so on
in this moment there may come a time
when you know the wide open trading
system that we championed around the
world in the immediate
post-world war ii era is good for us
again but it isn't right now I don't
think all of the stuff is contextual
that's when I say about prudence there's
no easy answer to this you have to come
to it with a decent understanding of
what you're trying to achieve of what
the good is what the political good is
then you have a debate with your fellow
citizens and you see who wins and you
see what gets enacted so one very other
short anecdote I a couple of months ago
I gave I was invited to give a talk to
this small group of like high achieving
people in Washington and they come in
from around the country they meet
somewhere I don't I think the speaker
canceled that's why oh yeah I meant to I
meant to say what are you guys all it's
the all-star game and you're here
listening to me I mean what did you not
have tickets or something I feel bad for
you so they invite me and it's a bunch
of like real Davos quality oligarchs in
here right none of them household names
I recognize but everybody in there is in
some like you know super rarefied
position in a corporation or in the
economy and they hear me give my little
spiel and they're of course naturally
terrified and horrified and this is one
guy system me you know well but I run
the tech company San Bruno and I can't
hire you know I said well I do try
paying them more well you know I know
even at any price I can and you know and
then we goes down this route so you know
what are you saying cuz I had made the
argument we don't need more people I
think right now at 327 million United
States it's not at the moment have a
pressing need for more people and what
am I supposed to do it in this so how do
we decide this question I said if the
regime operated the way it's supposed to
operate and you were senator Smith and I
were senator an time we'd argue about
this we would debate it you tell me why
you thought it was necessary I tell you
why you thought it wasn't necessary we'd
see who could marshal the most votes we
vote on it we would make a political
decision you might win that argument I
might win that argument I don't know but
that's not the ground on which we're
arguing about it today and that's what
fundamentally needs to change
so in the in the present crisis how can
conservatives revitalize politics
without without falling into
polarization well I mean polarization
what amongst ourselves or with the I
mean we're already kind of polarized
with the left and that there actually
does have a lot to do with that and I
don't think we're going to talk them out
of it so a certain amount of that is if
not necessary inevitable and we just
need to deal with it and in fact not let
our so one of the things I think
conservative to do is they let
themselves get talked into believing the
polarization is evil but what the left
means is it's even when you do it so
just back down and agree with us right
that's it concerns there's a lot of
high-minded conservatives who sort of
think that way oh we can't you know it's
just it's against my principle some
polarization politics is a fight I don't
remember the Latin but what's that that
line in Latin Aristotle is accustomed to
seeking the fight right it's you see a
quoted a lot the point is when you're
arguing about important true you know
things that the noble and the good the
just the true the beneficial people are
going to draw lines they're going to
take sides I'm gonna get mad at each
other than gonna yell at each other
there's no avoiding it you don't want it
to come to violence you don't want it to
come to division but if you know
avoiding polarization is the highest
good we're just gonna keep on the
trajectory that we're on and I don't
think that's good we're going to end
well
thank you for it so much for speaking
mr. Anton when ranley against the
tyranny of expertise you said we're
losing a rhetorical war because we make
mistake policy for principle it seems to
me though that president from President
Trump won in 2016 in large part because
of the list of proposed Supreme Court
nominees a list provided by expert legal
the expert legal establishment of
conservatism Inc the Federalist Society
how do you account for the huge number
of conservative voters who turned out
explicitly because of that list because
it was a list no I'm seriously I'm not
saying that there's there there's no I'm
not saying there's no use for expertise
I mean but let you know let's replace
expertise with the more important
fundamental word wisdom right expertise
is a specific type of knowledge that
claims to be wisdom that is not right of
course you know we always we always want
to be guided by wisdom by the truth by
knowledge of what is good good judges
are better than bad judges I would turn
to people who know a whole lot about
judges before making judicial
appointments and I would listen to their
advice but if the fundamental pointers
not that you don't listen to advice or
that you don't listen to wisdom or that
you don't gather and process information
right you're not you know rejecting
those things because you're anti
intellectual or you're just against
knowledge you're saying that your claim
to expertise does not give you the final
say this is still a fundamentally
political question so to take it back to
another one of those fundamental
tensions I was talking about in the
final analysis right the the the
classical argument is that the only just
claim to rule is wisdom and then they
spend a lot of time undercutting that
and showing you all the inherent
contradictions and saying well that's
never going to work but you have to
agree with them in principle the only
just title to rule is wisdom if you know
how to rule and I don't if you're wise
and I'm not you should call me the
factors make this point consistently in
the Federalist Papers and elsewhere
where they say if there were a perfect
being if God directly governed the
affairs of men of course we would let
him rule us as a without our consent as
a despot or an angel or something like
that but there's no human being who has
that we have to resolve these questions
for ourselves
they remain fundamentally political and
always will that's just in the nature of
man
thank you you talked about the
relationship between the universals and
the particulars and you said that it was
important that we don't abandon the
universals and simply try to make
decisions of based on particular issues
but in this talk we've heard about the
idea of protection and the good and
we're distancing ourselves away from
traditional principled move and
conservatism in ideas like the need for
liberty and virtue to be combined or in
terms of natural rights so if we're
moving away from those and simply going
after the good how does that stay how do
we stay away from utilitarianism with
that approach yes I'm not moving away
from natural rights or Liberty or virtue
I would argue that it's movement
conservatism that's forgotten how to
properly interpret these things and link
them together now that's really my
argument when I say they replace
principle with policy what I mean is to
them policies that might be good and it
might you know I mean a great example I
mean a bedrock principle of the founding
is the protection of property rights
hugely important as both as a
utilitarian measure it makes the country
a rich country as a stronger country and
as a moral measure the government really
shouldn't have the right to limit your
ability to use your talents to the
fullest right so they make the case both
ways but from there I think too many
conservatives how it would take that
principle and yet we're just gonna say
no no limits on acquisition or on
property rights can be ever set at all
and that because it's a principle and so
you know the argument against
protectionism of free trade are against
you know certain trade measures is one
of the arguments made is not merely they
make a utilitarian or you know this will
never work despite the fact that it has
worked in the past doesn't mean it'll
work now but at least we know it has but
they also makes a kind of what they
think is a moral argument which is that
this is somehow a government enter an
unjust government interference in
property rights I don't I don't see it
that way I think that misunderstands
what the what the founding principles
were and what these higher thing is that
you're talking about are that
my criticism it's not that we're a bit
more abandoning natural right Liberty
it's that we're trying to recover them
and their proper relationship with one
another against a movement that if it
ever really understood them maybe did 30
years ago it doesn't seem to anymore my
best thank you so much for speaking sir
you began your speech by talking about
the lincoln-douglas debates and both
candidates making arguments about
history to try to convince their voters
of certain first principles you have
essentially said tried to do that same
thing today making an argument about
history of the founding to convince us
of certain first principles but Stephen
Douglas was not convinced by Lincoln's
argument and there will likely be many
conservatives who are not convinced by
your argument
count on it respectfully I personally
happen to agree with you and even more
so there are many on the far right and
the far left who say we need to reject
the tradition of the founding in general
so is there a way to speak about
political values in a way that can
convince other people who disagree with
you without necessarily relying on the
institution of history well first thing
we need to do is not just banish the
word values from in this context for
reasons I can go into later that gets a
little abstruse so I thought your your
question is what can we do this without
appealing to history
I mean look there there may be but why
would you want to it's a wonderful
Arsenal or sorry tool in the rhetorical
Arsenal so we can evaluate the founders
on two bases well more than two but just
let's say are their principles true I
haven't examined them with great
diligence for a long time and I believe
they are and certainly have not found a
better alternative did they work out in
practice did they deliver what they said
they were going to deliver to us and all
of the writings that they put out and
justifying the revolution they did it
worked and and and third is it ours is
it inspiring to us is it something that
we can look back to a sector or a
republic if it wishes to live long let's
go back to its beginnings we don't go
back to the beginnings of others we go
back to what's our own because that's
part
you know human passion is to love one's
own it so happens that our own is good
and we don't need to lose sight at we
shouldn't lose sight of that that's what
I mean when I talk about the universal
but it's also our own it's particular so
I would do them I would use them both in
there in the rhetorical toolkit and do
and we'll I don't I don't see how we
gain anything by giving up the one or
the other that was the point I was
trying to make at the end by some on the
disgruntled right who get what's wrong
with movement conservatism but their
view is ditch the principle and just
embrace the particular alone that's not
ultimately I don't think that's that's
going to work and it's and it's
unnecessary that's just a flip that so I
essentially I think what they're arguing
for is the flip side of what you maybe
didn't argue for it but ask
[Applause]